BIDEN IS NOW TRYING TO CLAIM
REPUBLICANS ARE LYING ABOUT
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
>> HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
REPUBLICANS WHO TRY TO PAINT YOU
AND YOUR PARTY AS ANTI-POLICE?
>> THEY'RE LYING.
>> WHAT ABOUT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, THOUGH?
>> NO, I NEVER, NEVER, NEVER
SAID DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> SO, LET'S REFRESH HIS MEMORY
ON WHICH PARTY WANTS TO CUT
FUNDING TO THE COPS.
>> YES, I SUPPORT THE DEFUND
MOVEMENT.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO
DEFUND, BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE
AND START A NEW.
>> WHY USE THE WORD DEFUND, WHY
USE THE WORD DEFUND?
THIS IS THE WORD COMING FROM THE
STREET.
>> I AM FOR DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
>> A MOMENT TO REIMAGINE
POLICING.
>> IN MANY CITIES IN AMERICA,
OVER ONE-THIRD OF THEIR CITY
BUDGET GOES TO POLICE SO WE HAVE
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
>> CAN WE AGREE THAT WE CAN
REDIRECT SOME OF THE FUNDING?
>> YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> JESSICA?
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> DON'T FALL ON IT.
>> SO JOE BIDEN -- THE
QUESTION -- IF IT WAS JUST HAVE
YOU EVER ADVOCATED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE JOE BIDEN WOULD BE RIGHT
TO SAY THEY'RE LYING.
JOE BIDEN HAS NEVER ADVOCATED
FOR THAT.
>> HE SAID REDIRECT.
>> REDIRECTING IS NOT ACTUALLY
DEFUNDING.
>> HE SAID REDIRECT MONEY FROM
THE POLICE.
>> RIGHT, TO, WHAT?
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE THAT LIKE
NAIL SALONS?
THEY'VE EVEN DONE THIS IN NEW
YORK CITY AND THERE'S
PRELIMINARY RESULTS THAT SENDING
SOME 911 CALLS TO PEOPLE LIKE
SOCIAL WORKERS IS MAKING A BIG
DIFFERENCE VERSUS SENDING
POLICE -- I'M JUST TELLING YOU
THE FACTS.
>> SHE'S POINTING THE GUN AT ME
COME QUICK.
>> BUT THAT'S NOT ALL THE CALLS
THAT GO TO 911 OBVIOUSLY.
JOE BIDEN --
>> LET'S DRILL DOWN ON THIS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THE 911
OPERATOR WAITS AND THEN LISTENS
AND THEN SLOWLY MAKES A
DETERMINATION WHETHER OR NOT TO
SEND REAL 911 OR WHETHER IT
DESERVES A SOCIAL WORKER.
YOU THINK THAT THAT'S JUST SPLIT
SECOND DECISION THAT'S GOING TO
BE GOOD EVERY TIME.
>> IT'S NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO
BE GOOD EVERY TIME BUT IF YOU
CAN HAVE MORE EFFECTIVE --
>> IF I WAS A VICTIM I WANT IT
TO BE GOOD EVERY TIME.
>> NOT EVERY CALL TO 911 IS HE
HAS A GUN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CALL 911 FOR
OTHER SORTS OF THINGS WHERE A
POLICE OFFICER SHOWING US ARMED
IS NOT GOING TO BE THE RIGHT
APPROACH.
BUT EITHER WAY, OBVIOUSLY THE
MONTAGE IS REAL, EVERY MEMBER OF
THE SQUAD ADVOCATED TO THIS,
NANCY PELOSI DIDN'T, CLIBURN
DIDN'T, JOE BIDEN DIDN'T.
PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF POWER.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY A BAD ISSUE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
WE DON'T WANT TO GO IN THE
MIDTERMS WITH IT HANGING OVER
OUR HEAD.
>> THAT'S ALL WE WANTED YOU TO
SAY.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU SAY THAT?
I COULD HAVE AVOIDED TWO MINUTES
OF CHAT.
>> ALL RIGHT, GREG, IT'S PRETTY
BAD THAT YOUR BIGGEST DEFENSE IS
UH-UH, THEY DID IT.
>> I DO NOT BLAME JOE BIDEN AT
ALL.
HE CLEARLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
INTERNET.
AND HE ALSO DOESN'T WATCH FOX.
BECAUSE IF HE STUCK TO HIS
NORMAL MENU OF NEWS, YOU MAY NOT
NEVER HAVE HEARD THIS BEFORE.
IT WAS LIKE THE FINE PEOPLE
HOAX.
IT WAS NEWS TO HIM IT WASN'T
TRUE.
THAT'S WHY IT TOOK HIM LIKE A
YEAR TO STOP SAYING IT.
AND ALSO HE DOESN'T GET ANY PUSH
BACK EITHER.
YOU SAW DON LEMON JUST NODDING
ALONG LIKE HE'S LISTENING TO
JOSH ROGEN.
JOE'S LIKE AN UNDISCIPLINED KID,
HE CAN BREAK THINGS AND THROW
TANTRUMS BUT THE DOES ITTING
PARENTS ARE THE MEDIA AND
THEY'RE, OH, HE'S SO ADORABLE
WHEN HE LIES.
ISN'T THAT CUTE?
MAYBE HE REALLY BELIEVES THAT.
NO ONE WILL CALL HIM ON IT SO
THE BIGGER PROBLEM IS THE DEMS
HAVE TURNED BASIC NEED INTO A
POLITICAL FOOTBALL AND THE
PEOPLE PLAYING WITH FOOTBALL ARE
IMMUNE TO THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR ACTION, BEHIND GATED
COMMUNITIES WE SAY THAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BUT THERE'S A WEIRD
LET THEM EAT CAKE HERE,
ESPECIALLY AMONG THE NATIONAL
NEWS MEDIA, IT'S NOT HAPPENING
EXACTLY OUTSIDE THEIR DOOR SO
THEY DON'T REALLY CARE.
I THINK THE SOLUTION WILL NOT
COME FROM REPUBLICANS, BECAUSE
NO ONE'S GOING TO LISTEN TO
THEM, NO ONE IS GOING TO LISTEN
TO FOX.
THEY'RE GOING TO PEOPLE LIKE
JESSICA OR HAROLD FORD.
MODERATE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
EXPUNGE THE ELITE CLASS
DELIBERATELY OUR NATION BY THE
TENANTS OF JUSTICE.
AND THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN DO
THAT ARE DEMOCRATS LIKE JESSICA.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A STANCE.
IF WE HAVE NUTERS ON THE OTHER
SIDE WE'RE GOOD AT BOOTING THEM
TO THE STREET.
IT'S TIME.
YOU HAVE A NUGGET OF NUT BAGS
WHO WANT TO DESTROY THE COUNTRY.
>> BOOT YOUR NUTERS, JESSICA.
>> BOOT YOUR NUTERS.
>> TAKE IT.
>> DON'T THESE PEOPLE IN POWER,
THESE LEFT WING NUTS, TO USE
YOUR WORD, DON'T THEY LISTEN TO
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE ON
LOCAL TV AND ON FOX NEWS WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR LOVED ONES
WHO -- THERE WAS A WOMAN ON
EARLIER ON FOX NEWS WHOSE SON
WAS MURDERED, AND THE
PROSECUTOR, THE CIRCUIT
ATTORNEY, CUT A DEAL ON HER
SON'S MURDERER.
AND SHE -- I GUESS THEY'RE
IGNORING THAT.
AND THEY'RE ALSO -- THERE'S A
BIGGER LIE THAT'S GOING ON HERE.
AND, BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN, AND
I SAY THIS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS BOTH
PROPOSED GETTING RID OF CASH
BAIL.
THAT IS THE REVOLVING DOOR THAT
IS CAUSED A SPIKE IN CRIME HERE
IN NEW YORK AND IN OTHER PLACES.
BUT THEY'RE ALL PART OF THIS
LIBERAL ECOSYSTEM FROM THE
LUNATICS IN WASHINGTON TO THE
LEFT WING GOVERNORS, THE MAYORS,
THE CITY COUNCIL, THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS WHO HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THESE POLICIES THAT PAMPER THE
PERPETRATORS.
GAVIN NEWSOME SAID SOMETHING
YESTERDAY AND I WANT TO PUSH
BACK ON IT.
I FORGOT TO YESTERDAY.
HE SAID THE EVIDENCE DOESN'T
BACK IT UP.
OVER THE LAST THREE DECADES,
WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN CRIME IN
HIS STATE AND THEY SAY IT ABOUT
OTHER PLACES.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THERE WERE POLICIES IN
PLACE THAT YOU HAVE RIPPED UP.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT THREE DECADES
WHERE IT WAS CONSERVATIVE
POLICIES THAT CRACKED DOWN ON
CRIME, THAT PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL.
AND I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
JUST REICH HERE IN NEW YORK, IN
CALIFORNIA, THE VIOLENT CRIME
RATE WENT UP LAST YEAR, THE RAIN
RATE FELL BUT AGGRAVATED ASSAULT
INCREASED.
AND SO HE'S, AGAIN, FOCUSING
ON -- HE'S TRYING TO TAKE CREDIT
FOR SOMETHING HE DIDN'T DO.
>> HE'S BEING VERY DISHONEST
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT RECORDING
THE CRIME.
SO IF YOU DON'T ARREST ANYBODY
OR YOU DON'T FROM ANYBODY IT'S
NOT IN THE RECORD AND YOU CAN
SAY, HEY, LOOK, THE STATISTICS
ARE LESS THAN LAST YEAR SO
THEREFORE CRIME IS GOING DOWN.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE PART OF
THE LITERAL DEFUNDING MONETARILY
OF THE POLICE TO DEFUND THE
POLICE.
I MEAN, DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE
BOARD HAVE ADOPTED THE BLM
MESSAGE, THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT.
THEY DIDN'T SPEAK OUT LAST
SUMMER WHEN CITIES WERE BURNING
AND THEY WERE CAUSING $2 BILLION
WORTH OF DAMAGE WHICH OF COURSE
DEMORE MORAL ICED THE POLICE.
THEY BASICALLY PAINTED EVERY
SINGLE POLICE OFFICER IN THE
COUNTRY WITH THIS RACISM
ARGUMENT THAT IF YOU'RE A WHITE
POLICE OFFICER YOU'RE OUT TO GET
BLACK MEN EVERY SINGLE TIME YOU
WAKE UP AND PUT ON YOUR BADGE
AND GO OUT ON THE STREET THAT'S
DEMORAL ICING WHICH IS WHY
YOU'RE SEEING MASS RETIREMENTS,
NOBODY SIGNING UP TO DO THE JOB.
ALSO IT'S AMAZING HOW DEMS HAVE
EMBRACED BLM WHICH IS PROVEN
ITSELF TO NOT BE A MOVEMENT
AGAINST BLACK LIVES, OR THEY
WOULD SPEAK OUT ON ALL THE CRIME
IN BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS, BUT
REALLY ABOUT ENRICHING
THEMSELVES AND TAKING THE
COUNTRY MORE TO A MARXIST
ECONOMY THAN THE WHAT WE HAVE
NOW.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY I WANT
TO DEFUND LIKE ILHAN OMAR O